professor Lessig teaches family law and
often time family law cuts into a lot of
different topics whether it's
immigration migration she also focuses
on Indian law and one of the reasons I
was really passionate about this book is
that I listened to a podcast all about
Indian law and heard Marcia and the
minute I saw this book I became really
passionate about it
the book is fantastically written and it
really provides an interesting
perspective a contemporary view on
mail-order brides and grooms so when she
decided you know when she emailed me I
was more than happy to bring her to
California to speak she so this is your
first book yes it is Marcia's first book
buying a bride and engaging history of
mail order matches which was reviewed by
The New Yorker the Atlantic and The
Times Literary Supplement she has also
written articles a separation
deportation and termination should I
stay or should I go which exposed the
growing practice of separating fit
immigrant parents from their American
citizen children garnering national
attention so much of her work and
continuing her work will be more and
more important so I definitely encourage
you to read more of her articles there
was a great podcast about the Jamestown
part of her book which you can certainly
listen to she's also advised national
organizations such as the women's
refugee Commission the National
Children's Child Welfare Association and
the Southern Poverty Law Center on legal
issues facing Native Americans and
immigrant families she's a wonderful
person to talk to her book is great
please purchase a book if you can and
and explore her work and we're so happy
to have her so thank you for coming
[Applause]
hi well thank you so much for coming
tonight I want to thank Patty and the
California historical society not
Association and especially on this rainy
day but I think that's making you all
very happy right because you haven't had
rain I said y'all that's because I've
now lived in the south for ten years and
that's all the south you're gonna get
from me from New York City but I want to
give you before I start today about the
California portion of the book I want to
give you a little sense of how the book
happened and my thought process maybe
it'll be similar to some of what you all
you all are thinking I used to say you
guys I'm from New York and I came into
this book with the idea that well
noticing that there seem to be a
conflict that the historical
representation of Miller a bride seemed
good I was a big Little House on the
Prairie fan there's a book Sarah Plain
and Tall that I loved and this idea of
these pioneer women who went west often
as mail-order brides and helped settle
the West and they were lauded as heroes
and you know we loved them and then
there was this modern-day image of the
Miller a bride as this abused and
exploited woman who needs to be saved
and the practice should be stopped it
needs to be you know certainly regulated
highly and I was like how do we have
these two images one of them has to be
somewhat wrong and I went into the book
thinking it's the historical one that
we're using you know the rose-colored
glasses of history to misremember
what actually happened and what I found
is I was doing the historical research
and writing the book was that actually
the good parts of mail or marriage
continue to exist today and there are a
lot of benefits of mail-order marriage
so I want to know why why the change in
perception and California's history is
really interesting because it was both
at the forefront of these pioneer
mail-order brides and us
at the forefront of the changing
perception of milder brides so I'm gonna
talk about two separate periods of
history of California history the gold
rush mail-order brides the women who
started coming over in 18-49 and then
the focus on the Asia mail-order brides
the Japanese picture brides in
particular and how we got this change so
let's see I want to start with a sense
of why Miller Brides happened in the
West so this is a map this is actually a
little later than the period I'm talking
about this is a map taken from the 1870
census the white area is where you have
gender parity the darker area is where
you have more men what do you notice
okay I'm not a professor right now you
notice so I'm going to answer my
question you notice that on the East
Coast you have relative gender parity
the further west you go the more men you
get okay so as the frontier is expanding
you get a situation where there are way
more men than women well okay so
California in particular really
exacerbates this because this is a kind
of normal pioneer migration story that
this map here shows where everyone moves
just a little bit west at a time but as
soon as everyone in this audience knows
you know California was different right
gold so gold made people come out here
real fast a lot of them primarily men so
all of a sudden instead of the slow
settling that you had been getting up
until this point you get a rush a gold
rush right so all of these men start
rushing out to California and they leave
the women behind and that's okay for a
little while but men get lonely and then
we need to figure out what we should do
about it
and not only do men get lonely they also
large groups of men are not always
considered a good thing
so one of the first ideas came from this
woman so her name is Eliza Farnum and
she had inherited land in California in
18-49 her husband had come out here to
settle some you know to stake his claim
and he dies she had been left back home
with their two young sons he dies and
she knows if she doesn't come out to
California she's gonna lose her land she
needs to get out here but she's a very
proper East Coast woman and she's been
hearing some bad things about California
California does not have a great
reputation and this is California's
reputation that everyone is violent and
shooting each other in the face and
maybe not you know quite that way but
this is not a place that you want to
bring two small children
okay so Eliza had some interesting ideas
she thought that the way you tame men is
you bring out women right that the
reason these guys are dangerous and
violent and she doesn't want to be near
them is because they don't have the
civilizing influence of women okay so
she comes up with an idea let's bring
women so she starts she does this call
for bride the California Association of
American women and it is widely endorsed
both on the East Coast and on the west
coast on the East Coast you get all
these you know famous people who are
this is a great idea this is wonderful
no one's better to lead this and then
Farnam she she was very well known at
this point she had been the matron of
Sing Sing prison out east she was a doer
she got things done right so they're all
behind her and not simply out of like
the kindness of their hearts there
there's some other things going on her
proposal to bring out Brides was not the
first female migration program before
this throughout the 1830s early 1840s
every time
there was unrest in the East when
factories start closing down and female
factory workers are getting laid off
they start striking they want equal pay
things like that that are annoying and
you want to get rid of them
so the idea from the Reformers was we'll
just move them we'll move them out west
get rid of them those unruly women they
cause problems
move them out west where you know
they're wanted because out west you know
they'll take the unruly women because
they don't have anything else and we'll
talk about what they actually have but
that's the idea so there had been you
know a couple decades worth of these
programs of moving women out west for
jobs a lot of them became schoolteachers
and this was well supported it was well
was well accepted and her program was
similar so it wasn't that she proposed
something so radical the difference with
Barnum's program though was there wasn't
any pretense that oh they're gonna go
out and become schoolteachers first or
seamstresses or something these women
are coming out to marry the men and
civilize them okay now California not
surprisingly is pretty thrilled with
this idea they the Alta California which
is one of the California papers they
wrote when they find about out about
farnum's plan they write this is the
most gladdening intelligence of the day
Eliza Farnham and her girls are coming
and the dawning of brighter days for a
golden land even now perceptible the day
of regeneration is nigh at hand we shall
prepare ourselves to witness the great
change which is shortly to follow with
feelings akin to hilarious joy so
they're super excited okay now I should
step back for a minute I showed you the
map of the gender disparity but you know
California wasn't devoid of women right
there are plenty of native women in
California and one of the questions that
comes up a lot in this history of Miller
marriage is the relationship between the
settler men and the indigenous women
and sometimes the men wound up wanting
to have relationships with the local
Indian women and that was the reason for
bringing millet or brides because that
was considered bad so you know I have a
whole chapter on Jamestown and the feet
are up in Canada and that was a big
concern of the government because these
men were abandoning the colonies so for
instance Jamestown if you sort you know
remember hearing about it not a nice
place to live for a long time one of the
quotes I have about it in the book is
Jamestown a misery a hill a death not
good tourist you know tourism material
kind of brochure thing there women
didn't want to come
the men were you know dying they were
starving disease all this kind of stuff
but you know those Indian villages next
door they had food and they were doing
much better and all the men kept
abandoning Jamestown and other
settlements for the Indian villages and
marrying the Indian women and that was
one of the reasons why you get colonial
military brides California is a little
different they do have relationships
with the indigenous women but not so
good so it seemed to be something with
the dangerousness of California the the
group the mob mentality but these men
were not marrying the Indian women they
were actually attacking them so there
was a lot of sexual violence out in
California to the extent that within a
generation
the female the the Indian female
population in California was decimated
if you look at the census figures
between 1850 and 1870 men indian men
vastly outnumber indian women it's a
very very dangerous time to be an indian
woman so the men were having some sort
of relationship with these women but
they weren't looking to them as marriage
material and it was it certainly wasn't
curbing their violent instincts this is
different than what you get in a lot of
other places intermarriage with native
women was
common in the West usually amongst
trappers so when it was smaller groups
that went west and they often had
relationships with the tribes because
they help them with their trapping and
collecting a furs then you had a lot
more intermarriage and that was one of
the reasons why places like Oregon and
Washington wanted Miller brides but that
wasn't so much what was happening in
California there also seems to have been
worse relationships between you know the
settlers and the tribes in general there
are a whole bunch of horror stories
about men who do have relationships with
Indian women and then the Indian women
kill them in their sleep and cut them up
into little pieces and you know stories
like this so there was a big fear of
actually having a relationship with
Native women so that wasn't so much what
was going on in California so if you
can't have relationship with the Indian
women and there are no other women you
know this is a nice Indian intermarriage
family but it's not from California then
the idea of bringing out women gets you
very excited so here's a little cartoon
about a live woman in the mines you know
this guy has a wife all the other men
are so proud of him they're all so happy
for him this is so exciting
okay so that's great that seems to be
you know the idea but when Farnum says
I'm gonna bring out women they get super
excited because otherwise they're stuck
with this yeah everybody oh yeah they're
adorable right but they're still trying
to have their dances but there are no
women around okay so the men want women
great fine here's another one what about
the women right just because men want
the women to come out doesn't mean it's
a good thing for the women to come out
you know they're stag dance so one of
the things that goes wrong with farnum's
plan is she actually doesn't think about
that so for Farnum farnum's one of those
Victorian I mean you can see from her
picture right very tightly blunt hair
and very proper and
doesn't look like she smiles much and
her idea was she wanted to bring you
know very proper middle-class women out
to California to tame the miners and
teach them you know good Christian
values and how to you know not be all
not only violent but just debauched and
all those sorts of things right and her
appeal is not great she appeals
basically to women's idea of duty right
so she says she implored the women to
sacrifice their Eastern comforts for and
this is her advertisement here leaving
their seat of luxury by the fireside of
an Eastern home and their memberships
and the resorts of the gay in order to
save the Western man from sin and
debauchery well you know if you're a
middle class woman you want to travel
all the way out to California which
doesn't have a great reputation leave
the comforts of your middle-class home
which by the way are not so comfortable
right there's a there's an interesting
tally so Lydia Marie child makes this
tally of her year's housework and she's
middle-class East Coast middle-class
woman 360 dinners 362 breakfasts sitting
room and kitchen swept and dusted 350
times lamps failed 362 times the chamber
and stairs swept and dusted 40 times I
mean it's not like so easy out East and
Farnam saying hey leave these comforts
for even less comfort out west
so the middle-class women weren't
interested they said thanks but no
thanks but the working class and lower
class women were interested because
their lives out east weren't so great
they didn't have these comforts
necessarily they're getting kicked out
of a lot of their factory jobs their
wages are going down they're not being
treated very well at East and they're
interested so about two to three hundred
of them apply for farnum's program but
they're not the women she's looking for
she winds up not taking them in the end
she takes like three one of whom leaves
with the ship's captain around the you
know
somewhere in Brazil she so it's really
like her her maid and one other person
so her program winds up not being a
success but it also highlights what
would work so she's too focused on just
saving the men and she doesn't focus on
what would be in the interest of the
women right if you don't appeal to the
women they're not going to come as
Miller brides but it's also highlights
some of the stuff that California should
do so California starts appealing to
Eastern women to make them come out here
and they're a couple different things
that they do two of which are very
successful and will get repeated by
later states with their milder bride
programs that make them very successful
as well so the two big things her
divorce and property out east you know
we have the women's rights movement
going on at this time you have the
Seneca Falls convention but the laws
aren't changing so quickly partially
because they don't really have to write
women there they're protesting and all
of that but there are enough of them we
don't really have to listen to them
California wants women to come so one of
the first things that they do is that
they decide that we're gonna get rid of
the common law property regime which is
the coverture property regime which
means that when a woman marries a man
her legal identity gets covered by his
she no longer has a legal identity and
more more importantly for this she no
longer has her own property rights this
was one of the big things that the women
on the women's rights movement on the
East Coast was trying to get rid of that
married women would be able to keep
their separate property property that
they bring into the marriage and
property that they earn during the
marriage because it seemed fairly you
know unfair that what you get married
and now your husband has all of your
property that you bring into it and that
you earn during the marriage and there's
nothing you can do about it you now have
to ask him for money for anything that
you might want and he has no obligation
to give it to you
so women out east are very upset about
this system
fornia goes well since we're you know
Creon areare laws anyway why don't we
not do that and not only you know I'm
not guessing at what they're thinking
when you actually look at the
transcripts from the Constitutional
Convention Constitutional Convention
they say things like being a bachelor
with the hope of one day getting married
I think we should not adopt those
Eastern property laws they know exactly
what they're doing they're trying to
make the laws in California attractive
so that women who are thinking you know
who might be inclined to immigrate will
have a stronger incentive to do it so
that's the they changed the property law
and you actually do see that this
changes how the women out in California
view their worth they recognize that
they're valuable out here and they have
power because of that so there's this
great ad that I love from this
Marysville California woman she actually
places an advertisement in a newspaper
for her husband says a husband wanted by
a lady who can wash cook scour so milks
been we've hope can't plow cut wood
makes fires beats the pigs raised
chickens rock the cradle gold rocker I
thank you sir saw playing drive nails
etc these are a few of the solid
branches now for the ornamental long
time ago she went as far as syntax read
Murray's geography and through to rules
and Pikes grammar could find six states
on the Atlas could read and you can see
she can write can know could paint roses
butterfly ships etc could once dance can
write a horse donkey or oxen besides a
great many things too numerous to be
named here oh I hear you ask could she
scold
no she can't you blank blank
good-for-nothing blank now for her terms
her age is none of your business
she is neither handsome nor fright yet
an old man need not apply nor any who
have not a little more education than
she has and a great deal more gold for
there must be 20 thousand dollars
settled on her before she will bind
herself to perform all of the above
this is not something you would see on
the East Coast right but out here she
knows with this gender disparity that
the men are willing to recognize the
value of women and she's upfront she
knows look I can do all of these things
and it is valuable and not only as she
asked me for this money but because of
the way the law has changed in
California if she's paid it she gets to
keep it right so on the East Coast yes
you might get some sort of you know
dowry or something like that but your
husband has control of it until he dies
and you know you're hoping that he dies
before you otherwise you're out of luck
you never see that money again right
here this is her money she gets it if
this marriage doesn't work out she's got
protection right and the second part of
that is the other change which is the
divorce laws right so California decides
that they are going to have liberal
divorce laws and they do this for two
reasons one reason is well one reason is
to incentivize the women to take the
risk right you're going cross-country to
marry a man that you don't know well
that's risky no one's going to say it's
not but if you can get out of that
marriage it's a little less risky right
the other part of it is that it actually
kind of frees up women to marry more men
right we don't have polygamy but we can
have serial monogamy so again the idea
was you only get to keep your wife if
you can keep your wife right it's
marrying her doesn't automatically mean
she's your wife you have to convince her
every day to stay married to you because
there's a minor right next door who is
you know showing her his rocks I mean
the gold ones
you know she's gonna leave you for him
if you don't make marriage you know
worthwhile to her right and there's some
you know fun letters from East Coast
women about this there's one sort of
East Coast woman who's writing a little
scandalized she's writing back home to
her friends in New York Colonel
Stevenson of the New York regiment
presumably so on the who she and her
friend know who married a very pretty
woman who got divorced from one husband
to marry him and then she adds little
later that mrs. Bonner who ran away from
her husband with a mr. pluming
Columbus's is living here with him
married of course right so she's a
little you know but she's commenting on
all that's going around there's this
other California woman who I you know
admire a beam answer and she's cheeky ly
describing the benefits of California's
divorce laws she says I tell you that
the women are in great demand in this
country no matter whether they are
married or not you need not think
strange if you see me coming home with
some good-looking man some of these
times with a pocket full of rocks it's
all the go here for the ladies to leave
their husbands
two out of three do it so this is not
you know uncommon or unknown so
California sets up a situation where
they incentivize women who don't have
the greatest prospects out east to take
the risk of mail or marriage marry
someone that they don't know and you
know it's they're very much like the
49ers right it's a risk to come out here
there are a lot of dangers there's a lot
of uncertainty but the rewards can be
quite great and this is a and it works
very well within with I think it's
within 10 to 20 years California's at
gender parity it happened is very very
fast part of that has to do with
California California is an easier place
to live they get more families and
unfortunately one of things that happens
after that is one if they had gender
parity a lot of these rules disappear so
they don't stay the most progressive
state on women's rights that becomes
other states that need to start
incentivizing women to come you ever
wonder why Wyoming was the first state
that gave women the right to vote
it was read back then - it wasn't that
they were so progressive it was that
they realized that one of the best ways
to get women was to give them rights and
then actually a whole lot of you know
women's rights advocates start
advocating that women should move to
these places right move with your feet
and convince people that you know you
will not stay where you were not treated
fairly so California is the first of the
western states to consider Miller
marriage there is you know a lot that
they learn from Eliza farnum's failed
proposal right so even though she
doesn't actually bring over really any
mail-order brides her idea is then
replicated you know for the next 50
years or so there are these milder
bright expeditions that bring over east
groups of Eastern women to Western
mining towns Western logging towns and
are very very successful one of the most
successful ones is the Mercer girls
expedition which you may or may not have
heard about I write that about that in
the book as well and that one brings
hundreds of women out to the Washington
Territory okay so this is one story
right but then there's the second story
California is all in favor of these
women coming they support it they
changed their laws that's all well and
good
here are some lonely bachelors I am
partial to the one with the cat he looks
sensitive and you know fine then we get
a change
so the Miller Brides that I'm talking
about are white women and they're coming
out to marry the white wet men but soon
after you know this period you start
getting a lot of anti Asian sentiment
right Chinese immigrants have been
brought over to build the railroads that
was fine when they were you know being
built but now we're you know now
historically were in a recession
and there's all this anti-chinese
sentiment they're taking our jobs
there's a horrible cartoon you know the
Hobson's choice killing them or jumping
off the ledge
and you start getting all of these
immigration laws to exclude Chinese
immigrants from coming so you get the
Chinese Exclusion Act which borrowed all
laborers both male and female from
entering eventually we pretty much
through the laws prevent the majority of
Chinese immigrants from coming to this
country and the ones who are here if no
new immigrants can come they pretty much
can't marry her families and that was
intentional right
they couldn't naturalize so the only way
you would get a Chinese citizen you know
a person of Chinese descent to as an
American citizen is through birth
citizenship but you can't have babies if
there are no women so you want to stop
not only you know the male immigration
but they want to stop the female
immigration and they're successful with
the Chinese immigrants but during this
period we start getting a whole lot of
Japanese immigration which hadn't
happened before because Japan wasn't
letting anyone leave but things are
changing in Japan they're now letting
people leave Japan and things are bad in
Japan
so there's a big famine going on a lot
of the people a lot of the immigrants
who come over from Japan actually aren't
wouldn't necessarily consider themselves
Japanese at the time a lot of them were
Okinawans during this period okay now
what was conquered but or invaded by
Japan occupied by Japan they were very
oppressed by the Japanese rule I think
something like 60% of the Okinawan
population during this period leaves the
island so there's massive immigration
from Okinawa there's also occupation of
South Korea and so during this period
South Koreans are for purposes of
immigration law going to be considered
Japanese so you have the Chinese
Exclusion acts but those don't bar
Japanese immigrants
and quickly it becomes clear that this
is a loophole that needs to be closed
but Japan doesn't want an outright ban
so they come up with the gentleman's
agreement which is that you won't ban
you mean in the United States won't ban
Japanese from entering Japan will just
stop its own citizens from coming but we
will make an exception for wives of
Japanese immigrants who are already in
the United States so this is where you
get the rise of the creation of picture
brides because you have all of these
Japanese men who are in America they
can't marry anyone here there are very
few Japanese women in America at this
point anti-miscegenation laws mean that
they can't marry anyone who's not
Japanese and the gentleman's agreement
says if they are married they can bring
their wives over but it's dangerous for
them to leave the country because if
they leave the country two things might
happen one if they go back to Japan
there's a very good chance they're going
to get conscripted into the Emperor's
army which is not something most of them
want and the other problem is something
that we're seeing today which is it's
not at all clear that they're going to
get back into this country so what they
do is they start marrying picture brides
women whose pictures you know they they
meet through and advertisements or
intermediaries who they have no
relationship beforehand they're married
by proxy which mean which was recognized
in Japan as a valid marriage so then the
women come over here as their wives and
they are let into the country there's
still this is a hearing at Angel Island
there was a lot of questioning of these
women whether or not these were real
marriages things like that and it
becomes increasingly clear to a lot of
the white Californians that this
gentlemen's agreement isn't really
working because all of these women are
still coming over and they're getting
married to well they're married to these
men and then they're having babies and
there's all this stuff about their crazy
fertility rate oh my goodness Japanese
women are having you know baby a year
sometimes three yeah
not quite but you know this is we need
to stop this we need to shut this down
now you know before that happens and it
will happen the there are some other
arguments that are made the Japanese
brides are a little different than the
East Coast women who have more
protections right I was talking to you
about all of those California laws that
protect them the picture brides are in a
much more precarious situation if they
don't marry these men they have to they
need to get remarried when they come to
the United States because we're not so
sure about proxy marriages but if they
don't marry these men they can't stay
and they have to go back home which a
lot of them say you know will bring
shame on their families so they don't
really want to do that a lot of the men
lie to them but because of their
situation it's much harder for them to
just find someone else right in
California if the guy you come out if
you're a white Eastern woman and the guy
you come over to marry turns out to be
25 years older than he says he was and
the business that he is you know
president of turns out to be a fruit
stand on the corner you just go and you
know find someone else these women can't
they have to marry the men who their
papers say they're married to so they
are in a more precarious situation for
that reason one of the things that one
of the themes of the book is that the
more legal protections milder Brides
have the you know the better off they
are but even so a lot of the women do
decide to marry these men and they still
use the gender disparity to their
advantage so there are still aren't
enough women a lot of them wind up
working a lot of the the complaints that
they have is that the men they marry
don't work so the women do they do a lot
of cooking they do a lot of laundry as
they do things like that they make their
own money and a lot of them you know
stay with their husbands and raise
families but they're controlling the
money and they're powerful in their
relationships for that reason but a lot
of them also leave these guys they have
their own independent sources of income
now they're here and you see there are
these Japanese newspapers with whole
columns of Miller
brides who have left their husbands and
you know they've found other Japanese
men who will treat them better and they
leave for them
the divorce rate for the Japanese Miller
Brides is about four times as high as it
is for non Japanese women in California
at that time and the the anti Japanese
government basically uses this to show
that these women are morally debauched
and eventually use it uses it to show
that picture brides need to be shut down
and they are successful you know hear
concerns about the hordes of women just
entering and they start accusing them
all of actually being prostitutes and if
they're not prostitutes that there are
these debauched women who we don't want
here okay so the change that we see in
California is that when the race of the
women changes the acceptance of millar
marriage evaporates right now these
women are seen as a burden immigration
law as subverting or threatening the
obviously the racial purity of the
country and California again is at the
forefront of a movement with Miller
brides and immigration in general to ban
undesirable people or immigrant groups
that are considered undesirable from
entering the country
so the asian exclusion acts are the most
severe but what you start seeing on the
East Coast is a repetition of both
Eastern European Miller Brides using
Miller our marriage to subvert
restrictive immigration laws and then
the government tweaking these
immigration laws to try to catch these
women and keep them out of the country
so we have a situation where
California's history explains both the
respected glorified history of Miller
marriage when the women were seen as
helping the country part of the manifest
destiny they were supported they were
protected when they were seen as threats
then Miller marriage could become more
risky because they're not protected by
US laws but Miller marriage still
provided opportunities for women who
were you know to come to this country
who would otherwise have been excluded
and today so I'll leave you with this
this is still what's happening so the
people who come over use Miller marriage
to come over know that there are risks
but they come over because they believe
that the opportunities offered by mail
or marriage are superior to you know the
opportunities that they have at home we
have lots of laws in place to protect
them the more laws that we have the
safer it is for them to come the newest
group who is using Miller marriage are
gay men because if you think about
what's going on in lots of places in
Eastern Europe it's not so safe to be a
gay man or well a gay person there are
lots of anti-gay laws and now that we
have same-sex marriage same-sex couples
can use mail or marriage as well to come
to the front of the immigration line so
it's the same history happening over and
over again but we're also seeing right
with our immigration situation today
that how how long marriage and family
priority laughs is questionable this is
a debate that we've had for a long long
time about whether or not we should
prioritize workers or good immigrants
versus the bad immigrants or the family
immigrants
and we will we will see how that all
plays out so thank you very much
and I look forward to your questions you
mentioned that there were some people
who brought out hundreds of brides and
what was in it for the people who were
doing the bringing oh well there were a
number different things that's a great
question
money fame and love some you know
sometimes they wanted the women too so
it was like we all draw lots to see
who's going to be the person who goes
out east to bring back the brides
because we're all lonely here and there
could be money as well so I'll go back
and organize the bridal expedition and
each of you chip in a certain amount of
money and then you know I'll take my fee
from it
ASA Mercer who brings out the largest
group of brides he winds up he's elected
a president of the the new college he
winds up being a state legislator I love
him if you bring out women two lonely
men like your political career is set so
there were lots of incentives to do it
and not really the only downside would
be is if you fail at it then you're not
liked so if you you know say you're
gonna bring out all these women and you
ask for money and then you don't really
bring out any that could be a bad thing
but in most cases they were fairly
successful they didn't even have to
bring out that many for the men to be
quite pleased with them
so what's the like I'm thinking about
women from South America and Mexico so
what's the difference between bringing
you know 50 women from South America
into San Francisco they're not I don't
know are they marriage' below I guess
I'm thinking about men who brought women
in and then just prostituted them and
made them dance I mean it's how is that
different than mail-order brides well
that's a good question that's an
important question so I define very
specifically Miller marriage in this
book and what a Miller bride is a Miller
bride is not a trafficked woman it is
not a prostitute or she is not a
prostitute
it is a woman who chooses to immigrate
for marriage to marry someone that she
doesn't know but of her own volition
knowing that she is going for marriage
she is not tricked in I mean if if she
is tricked into becoming a prostitute
then she's a trafficked woman even if
even if they said she was going for
marriage but actually that that's a fear
that's around but when a lot so in
modern Miller marriage a lot of people
worried that the women are trafficked
that they're lied to that they're going
to be milder brides and then they turn
out not to be the trafficking tends to
be with lying about jobs so hey where
you can come to America we're going to
hire you to work at this sort of thing
because Miller marriage is not a good
way to bring over lots of women it's
just hard
you can only sponsor one man can only
sponsor in his lifetime a few more than
one but you know two three tops and then
that's it so you'd have to find a lot of
men willing to do this to bring over a
lot of women it's a lot easier to set up
a fake cleaning company or something and
get work permits to bring over women and
then wind up trafficking them so the
international trafficking organizations
that have looked into this have not
found that Miller marriage is the way
that women are trafficked into this
country so Miller if a woman is traffic
she is not a male or a bride by my def
and Miller brides have to be women who
choose to do this so arranged marriages
are also not Miller marriages the women
have to decide through their own
volition that this is something that
they want to do when a woman in a gold
rush era comes from the east to the west
when and how and who decides the the
woman is going to be matched with this
individual man for the first marriage
well the woman decides who she wants and
what happens is the ship pulls up into
the harbor in their Sunday best there's
been a run on all the suits all the
barber shops and all the men are there
and some of them have cruder tactics
than others in mining towns some of them
just show literally you know their big
gold rocks and propose as the women are
walking off the ship and sometimes that
worked what usually happened very few
women married right away what they did
was they said hold on all the men want
to marry right away like immediately
that day and the women said we're gonna
settle in we're gonna get to know you a
little bit and a lot of them worked for
a little while because you know there
was a demand for a lot of these female
skills right so they worked as
seamstresses and teachers and things
like that getting to know the men and
then they would pick who they wanted to
marry it was up to no one else and
they're promised that in these
agreements that they will not be forced
to marry that they don't have to marry
and once it allows some of them don't
marry almost all of them do but you know
a few of these women don't marry and
they're never made - and the men have to
convince them that it's in their
interest to marry the women who married
quickly tended to be women so with the
Mercer Brides there the New York Times
actually embedded a reporter with one of
the groups that goes out so he sends
back these dispatches to the east
because people are like fascinated by
the whole thing
and one of the women who marries right
away is this like eighty year old woman
who marries like a 25 year old and it's
her she wants to you know obviously she
went out there to get married
and you know he's got a funny kind of
description of her about how pleased she
is with her strapping young buck and
there's there's another a woman he
describes as a harried mother of many
young boys one of whom his neck he
nearly rung on the way over there so
she's a widow with many small children
and she needs help and she gets married
like the day the ship lands but most of
like you know the 20 year old women they
wait a little while and then they decide
which man they want to marry and then
eventually they do so pretty much all of
them marry within a year but very few of
them marry within a month I'm assuming
that it became less of an issue or it
happened less frequently once there was
a easier mode of transportation more
immigrants such as the Transcontinental
Railroad is that correct it changes so
you don't get these expeditions anymore
but you get actually the Golden Age of
male or a marriage is after you have the
railroad because now it's even less
risky right if I have to take you know a
couple month long ship ride that also
costs a whole lot of money I'm a little
more hesitant now it's like a three-day
train ride and if it doesn't work out I
can go back home and some of them do
though most of them don't when they come
out there so there are all these like
funny newspaper stories of you know he
failed to suit so good woman comes out
she takes one look at him today
mmm but she actually likes Wyoming so
she stays because all these other guys
are like hey you know stay well you know
maybe you'll like us and she's like okay
so she'll stay even if she doesn't marry
him
but there are instances where they just
turn around and go back home because it
is easier and more affordable the other
part of it is there's the real rise of
the really the classified ads for this
so now you have papers going back and
forth you have mail going
back and forth much easier so now
instead of women getting off ships and
seeing the men for the olds they're
still seeing the men for the first time
but they've been in contact with a
particular man so they've put these
advertisements in things like the
matrimonial news and Cupid's arrow and
there are tons of them and they all I
mean they're just they're 19th century
tinder basically right and you know they
had correspond with a particular man and
then they go out to meet that man and
that's because communication and
transportation has gotten so much easier
in the late in the second half of the
19th century that you actually get many
many more the other aspect of that is
that the Civil War right so now you have
an even greater gender disparity so
there are all of these women who have no
marital prospects out east because it's
not equal anymore all of these men died
if they want to get married they have a
much better chance if they go west where
fewer men died in the Civil War so a lot
of women really consider it in a way
they wouldn't have earlier what was the
situation on child support was it your
first husband you had children with and
you went to another husband was he
expected to support them well it was a
little different than it is today and
men had the right to the children this
was something that winds up changing and
that could be an issue
leaving them if if they were going to
enforce that but part of what's going on
in these female-friendly
Western states until they hit parity is
that they don't enforce a lot of these
laws that favor men so there's a very
interesting case from colonial Virginia
about a broken engagement and it's the
woman who does the jilting and under the
law she should be in trouble she should
be like in a lot of trouble but no one's
willing to convict her of anything
because there are so few women and she
has this power so you know the the
Virginia legislature kicks it over to
England which hems and ha
and eventually they do nothing and then
they make a legislative change saying if
this happens again we'll really do
something and then another woman does it
they're like oh well like say you're
sorry in the church and we'll forgive
you because women by virtue of their
scarcity have a power so even if the law
technically would be against them until
you have a situation where the men are
not really worried about pleasing the
women anymore those laws such that a man
would retain custody of his children
probably wouldn't be as enforced but I
have not seen one of those cases where a
woman has divorced her first male or her
husband for another man and then there
was a custody fight over the children I
think they were just able to take them
but I'm not sure good question
in your research did you find anything
about african-american women and
mail-order brides and the West yes they
were certainly not as numerous but there
were african-american Miller brides and
there was a group called the busy bee
Club which it was similar to Farnum this
is out in Tucson I think where they're
worried that the men are getting into
trouble because there aren't enough
women so they send back east and bring
women over there they're very very
similar in terms of the motivations for
what's going on you have a gender
disparity obviously you have the race
aspect of it that they can't marry white
women who are there but it's not there
aren't so many white women either and
what's different is there weren't so
many african-american men who there was
really not the concern of the
intermarriage with the native women the
way you had with the white men which was
a big factor in why a lot of the
governments were trying to support these
expeditions so I looked for that
research and there's some I wonder if
there's more out there
that I just wasn't able to find but
certainly they you know there are
examples of african-american women
coming out as mail-order brides and they
do so for the same reasons they're you
know convinced that they have better
prospects out west and you know a lot of
it has to do with you know this
situation back east post-civil war was
often not so good in the West had the
possibility of offering more equality hi
I was just curious you were talking
about the Japanese mail-order brides and
I think you said that if they decide
they don't marry this guy or they
divorce him they had an independent
source of income I was just curious what
was that independent source of income
for the Japanese mail-order brides marry
them to get off Angel Island so they
have to marry them initially but what a
lot of them did was these traditional
female jobs that there weren't women
doing so they were in you know
innkeepers waitresses barmaids
laundresses and they would you know
they'd be the ones running these
businesses so they would get the money
and that enabled them to seek to leave
their husbands in a way a lot of women
can't if they feel that they're
financially dependent on their husbands
so even if you know even if they don't
leave with a lot of money they have the
skills that allow them to leave and they
know that they can you know they have
these businesses that we're thriving
because you have these very large
Japanese communities with very very few
women and all the men want like a nice
home-cooked meal and you know lots of
them don't have most of them don't have
lives they want someone to do their
laundry you know the traditional female
work so they were able to get pretty
good wages doing that
when asked one more so with the goldrush
it was a whole lot of people from a
whole lot of different places a lot of
different cultures ethnicities whatnot
did the mail-order bride business sort
of follow the same sort of thing was
there a lot of mixing let's say somebody
from Spain would marry somebody from
South Carolina you know most of the
women who came over to the through these
Western expeditions were American born
they were Eastern Native women the men
they married may not all have been
that's an interesting question I've
never really noticed that are the the
backgrounds of the men they were you
know the 49ers and you know other people
who would but some of them certainly
might have been you know people coming
from Europe and other places like that
the women less so you don't get the
European milord or Brides again until
you start getting the the Napa in 1921
National Origins Act the 1924 quota act
because one of the things that those
laws do is make it almost impossible for
single women to immigrate to America
because you are considered a likely
public charge because you need a man to
sponsor you so there are all these women
there's horrible stories of all these
women who are like I've been on my own
for like 20 years making my way as a
seamstress I'm really skilled I have
money it's not gonna be a problem and
they're like yeah you need a guy and
they're sent back because they're going
to they're assumed to be a likely public
charge and we're gonna hear this term
again we're starting to about you know
poor people using our services this is
not a new idea so they were very
concerned about letting in poor
immigrants who would then need state
support and single women were just
automatically assumed basically to need
state support so if you were a single
woman who wanted to come to America your
best chance was through mail-order
marriage
so that's where you start getting a lot
of these mail-order brides otherwise
they would have before that they came
over by themselves it wasn't that Miller
marriage was if everything's equal
people don't choose Miller marriage
today people choose Miller marriage
again because it's not so easy to come
to this country the best way to come to
this country the easiest way is through
marriage to an American citizen so it
puts you at the top of the list if it
didn't put you at the top of the list I
don't think we'd have any mail-order
brides and I'm just curious about the
woman whose quote you shared with us
earlier who listed her attributes and
wanted the 20,000 gold rocks up front or
whatever she wanted did she get any
takers I wish I knew I have researched
her so much I want to know what happened
to her and I don't I I wish I did I I
bet she did I you know you don't put
that in there unless you think that you
have a shot and you see this I have a
whole chapter on the rise of matrimonial
ads and the difference between the male
ads and the female ads and the male ads
are all things they want the women to do
like you know I need someone to like
cook my food and wash my clothes and
take care of you know my cows or
whatever and the woman's our little
making it clear that they don't just
want to be some sort of Drudge you know
I'll come out there but I'm valuable and
you need to recognize it and I'm I'm
doing this because I want to increase my
marital prospects right especially as we
get into the later 19th century they can
marry on the East Coast there are people
they could marry but for various reasons
they may not have found someone that
they like so much so what does this do
it expands their options well maybe
someone out there is better maybe they
will appreciate me more you know one of
the things that's also going on East
Coast around this time is there's a
panic about surplus women yes right so
the surplus women scare is the idea that
there are too many single women
and you know what are we gonna do with
them they're ruining it comes mostly
from Britain but we have this on the
East Coast as well all of these
government officials are freaking out
that there are all these unmarried women
this is a problem we need to do
something about them if you're living in
a society that calls you a surplus woman
like maybe you want to go somewhere that
doesn't call you a surplus woman that
actually like wants you and when you get
off the boat they're like all excited
and happy hurrah you know so that's what
goes on a lot as well in in England
there are these women's right societies
that actually set up immigration
programs because they realize that
women's rights in England are just not
happening so quickly and that the best
thing for a lot of women is to
physically move from Britain which does
not appreciate them - that they go to
British Columbia which is a very similar
history as as we have in California and
the Pacific Northwest and there's a
whole issue there also about they need
women because the Americans are crossing
the border and are gonna like annex
British Columbia and they want them to
cross the border but they want them to
be Canadian so they have you know
they're like well these these Americans
won't stay here if there are no women so
we need to bring over women and then the
men will stay and then when we bridge so
there are all these political
implications as well about you know
making sure that you have enough of a
population in this case to like fight
off an American invasion so it's it's an
interesting history anyone else
I just love this stuff so what about the
Mormon women I just want to throw that
out there I don't know if that's like
completely separate or family groups I
didn't see any Mormon mail-order brides
and I think it's because they traveled
together so one of the things you see in
in the colonial period you don't have
Miller brides in the Northeast because
the Northeast colonists are the
religious refugees so the Puritans
they went with their women they traveled
in family groups so you didn't have a
gender disparity in the southern
colonies which were plantations which
were cash crops they were men who came
over to make their fortunes and you know
they didn't bring they didn't bring
women very much especially once it
became clear that things were terrible
things were terrible in the Northeast as
well but you know when you're getting
persecuted and you know potentially
killed they're still better right
so the Puritans are coming in family
groups in Virginia in Georgia and South
Carolina they're not when the women come
the first group come they think it's
awful
they you know they starve their Indian
raids they leave and the reputation of
what's going on in these southern
colonies gets back to England and no
women want to come anymore so it was
just different for that reason I think
the Mormons were like that too since
they moved in family groups you never
got a situation where you had large
groups of men without women we actually
have more of that problem now with if
each man gets a couple women than we
have then we have problems well it may
not be fair but it's actually
problematic there are all these stories
about you know kicking boys out of the
community partially so that you can have
more I mean if you have a 50/50 birth
rate but some men have like ten wives
then you have some men who have none so
you need to kind of get rid of those men
but that that's separate
I also teach family law so there is a
podcast on NPR that talked about the
need for multiple women in houses such
as polygamy for like ranching and doing
stuff like that but in California was
that really needed during the gold rush
because there was less of like that
ranch base like oh go out and like take
care of cattle but the men were out
hunting for gold was there was that
polygamy still a thing for a mail-order
bride it's like people are like I
already have two but let me get one more
well there was no polygamy at this time
you were lucky if you got one I mean it
may be in the Mormon communities but
Miller Brides would not have been in a
polygamous relationship because they had
the power right so what's interesting
that happens over and over again is
Miller brides are able to negotiate for
a better deal than their their
counterparts either back home in
different places so the the feeder ah
who are the Miller Brides in the New
France Colony they all enter into these
marital contracts which are way better
than anything the French women back home
would have had and you know they're
they're getting greater property
portions and it you know promises to do
or not do certain things and they have
you know more choice over the men and
there are all these laws that so I was
asked earlier if the women were ever
forced to marry no but sometimes the men
were so in New France if you did not
marry when you had the opportunity so if
you just want to be a bachelor then you
lost all of your hunting rights because
the government wanted everyone to get
married but they knew they couldn't
force the women the women you needed to
treat well the men you could actually
start finding and punishing if they did
not step up and you know do their duty
to you know populate the colony because
one of the things with New France as
well was that the French King didn't
really want to bring over so many
immigrants or you know yeah he didn't
want to depopulate France for New France
so he
decided that we're going to grow the
colony through natural means so it meant
that okay we're gonna bring over these
women but you better marry them and you
better have a lot of children with them
and actually they really did like if
anyone's here french-canadian you're
probably related to the fedora like I
think it's eighty percent of the current
French population is descended from
these eight hundred women I mean they
were they were they were having babies
that's chapter two any other well I'm
the descendant of a picture bride this
would be my Italian grandmother came to
New Mexico and married my Spanish
great-grandfather they communicated with
the photograph in letters but my
great-grandfather sent the money to
bring her back who paid for
transportation in the California bride
system well that was one of the reasons
why farnum's plan didn't work because
there was no one paying for it so the
farnum's plan fell apart because all the
the working-class women who wanted to do
it they didn't have their way pay for it
it was very very expensive then later on
once we have the railroads then it
usually was the men who paid to bring
them out they would send them a ticket
it was more affordable the like the
mercer brides the men took up a
collection and then mercer went back and
he chartered a ship and the women had
free passage usually in order to have a
successful Mildura bride program the men
need to pay the way for the women and
even today i mean if you look at modern
miller marriage the men typically are
paying for not only paying for the women
to come over but there's certain
financial requirements they need to have
a certain amount of income under US law
before they're allowed to sponsor a
mail-order bride so to make sure that
you know it needs to protect the women
we have a lot of the lot of laws that
currently that protect Miller brides one
of which would be to make sure that
they're marrying someone who
you know has a decent financial
situation but yes there were a lot of
Italian Miller Prize and part of the
reason for that is well what year would
this have been Oh a really long time ago
okay because I was going to say you know
Italians were also caught up in these
quota acts so a lot of them couldn't
come over because Italians Eastern
Europeans they were all limited to their
like census numbers from 1880 so your
came over really early and it worked
right a million kids in fact the
petracelli has a winery in Napa so yes
he had stretched even to California but
started in New Mexico I have actually
heard about quite a few have you know
descendants of picture brides mail-order
brides and people often wonder what the
rate of success is for mail-order
marriages and obviously I don't know
historically that's harder to say but
statistically speaking modern Miller
marriages are at least as successful and
likely more successful than the average
American marriage so I have theories for
why this is which I discuss in the book
but the short answer I think is that
Miller marriages you know what you're
getting you know what the benefit of
that marriage is and as long as both
people keep their end of the deal then
you have no reason to end the marriage
one of the reasons why we don't like
Miller marriage today is it seems
antithetical or to our concept of the
love match right you're marrying for
something that's awful love is much
better but you know marriage is based on
passion when the passion goes away a lot
of times people you know leave each
other looking for the next passion but
if you're marrying for stability and
financial reasons and so you know you
have someone to take care of the home
and do those things as long as the
people are still doing that you know
there's no reason for the marriage
and now then a lot now I'm getting some
faces can love happen in these marriages
yes definitely one of the quotes that I
end the last chapter with so the
interviewer there's an interviewer
asking a mail-order bride from Ukraine
whether or not she loves her husband and
she's like love love I wasn't thinking
about love when I you know I was in
Ukraine I was thinking about do I have
enough bread to feed my child and then
she goes but how could I not love a man
who's been so good to me and my daughter
I mean it
love is not usually at least for the
women the reason they start with these
marriages but if they're treated well
and they're happy in them there's no
reason why love can't come after well
thank you all so much
[Applause]
[Music]